et s'est invitée aujourd'hui c'est vous
bruno tertrais bonjour bonjour bienvenue
sur ce plateau politologue directeur
adjoint de la fondation pour la
recherche stratégique
votre dernier livre on en avait parlé
ensemble vous et moi s'appelle atlas des
frontières et les sorties aux arènes ya
quelques temps j'en parle parce qu'il va
falloir sans doute à nouveau le
réactualiser dans un avenir plus ou
moins proche la guerre en ukraine bien
sûr à redessiner les cartes et pas
seulement celles de l'europe de l'est on
va y revenir quelques mots d'abord on en
parlait à l'instant avec mariam quinze
années sur ce nouveau round de
négociations entre russes et ukrainiens
hier à istanbul en turquie et les
déclarations russes qui ont suivi de
quel côté est des analystes vous trouvez
vous des sceptiques des optimistes des
prudents des pessimistes très clairement
du côté des sceptiques voire des
pessimistes écoutez si la russie voulait
vraiment montré qu'elle elle est prête à
engager des négociations sérieuses sur
l'avenir de l'ukraine et sur la fin du
conflit elle ne donnerait pas les deux
signaux qu'il a données depuis 24 heures
à savoir on dit non à emmanuel macron
pour l'évacuation des civils de
marioupol pour une opération strictement
humanitaires et on ne continue pas les
opérations autour de kiev alors qu'on a
dit que finalement kiev ça ne nous
intéresse pas donc je suis extrêmement
sceptique ça veut pas dire qu'il faut
prendre il faut mettre de côté tout ce
que disent les russes mais en tout cas
moi ce que ça me dit ce contexte c'est
que le temps de la vraie négociation
n'est pas encore venu on se contente
pour l'instant de lancer quelques idées
comme ça pour voir comment l'autre
partie rech d'autant que ce semblant de
retrait militaire russe peut être aussi
vu comme une forme de reconnaissance des
limites opérationnelles
oui d'autant plus qu'on arrive au moment
après un petit peu plus d'un mois on a
eu au moment où 2 500 les forces russes
doivent se reconstituer il ya des
personnes qui vivent à des rotations de
personnel on connaît tous les problèmes
logistiques de l'armée russe donc celle
qui se retient légèrement c'est ça peut
être aussi pour mieux attaquer ensuite
alors à ce propos on a bien sûr beaucoup
dit ces derniers jours que l'armée russe
avait sous-estimé le rapport de force
avec les ukrainiens pour beaucoup de
raisons est-ce que là encore il faut pas
y mettre une forme de prudence avec ce
que cette analyse contient sans doute
d'éléments de communication une
craignent un et puis le fait que le
territoire ukrainien il suffit de le
regarder de regarder une carte a de
toute façon été grignotées en réalité
est que là pour le coup le recul est
assez inenvisageable oui alors il faut
quand même bien garder en tête puisque
on parlait de frontières tout à l'heure
que il ya vraiment deux questions
séparées la crimée c'est entre
guillemets perdu pour l'ukraine sans
doute pour très longtemps la question
c'est de savoir dans l'hypothèse où la
russie se contenterait du donbass est-ce
que ça serait un dôme basse tel qu'il
existe aujourd'hui enfin est-ce que ça
serait un retour à la situation d'il ya
un mois avec quelques territoires de
plus ou est-ce que la russie exigerait
comme c'est à mon sens très probable un
john bass élargie c'est à dire à damas
qui restent jusqu'à la crimée y compris
justement ce samedi bande côtière ou pas
ce mario paul hamon estime paul tombe là
ça change beaucoup de choses bien sûr
parce que je crois qu'avant à la fois en
termes symboliques et en terme de deux
territoires avoir une continuité pour la
réussite depuis le débat ce déjà occupé
jusqu'à la crim est annexée ça serait
quand même un vrai redécoupage des
frontières et d'ailleurs si ce
redécoupage avaient lieu avec
l'assentiment de la partie ukrainienne
ça donnerait des envies dans d'autres
parties de l'europe de l'est ce je pense
notamment à l'ex yougoslavie on en
reparlera mais voilà le redécoupage des
frontières par la force c'est quelque
chose qu'on est plus sensé faire en
europe si on recule la focale maintenant
et qu'on essaye d'analyser rapidement ce
que cette guerre provoque comme
déséquilibre mondial d'abord quelques
mots de la stratégie américaine comment
la comprenez vous comment comprenez vous
les mots rude et assumée du président à
baden mais je crois qu'il faut
distinguer ce que dit biden est ce que
fait l'administration américaine avec un
langage de plus en plus du haut vous
souvenez ça commence et 18 mois c'est un
tueur disait monsieur bailly donne à
propos de poutine puis ensuite c'est un
criminel de guerre puis enfin il doit
partir donc ça ça veut dire que byden a
fait son deuil de toute possibilité de
relation personnelle proche avec la
divers poutine il pourra encore le
prendre au téléphone vous savez vladimir
poutine ça n'impressionne pas on le
traite de criminel la guerre
malheureusement ça ne passionne pas mais
on n'aura pas pendant la présidence
byden pendant les deux ans et demi qui
reste on aura pas de grand some may et
d'embrassades ça c'est certain ça ne
veut pas dire qu'à côté l'administration
américaine ne peut pas travailler
travailler avec la russie vous savez les
diplomates russes ils ont le cuir épais
et bien tanné et donc ce qui veut dire
que eux qu'on le contraire de leur
président qui venait de la guerre ça ne
les empêche pas de travailler avec les
américains voilà sa ferme la porte à une
relation directe comme peu à voir
emmanuel macron justement qu'il ya des
bobos beaucoup plus prudents vis du
président russe safer la porte à de
futurs sommets importants entre by des
années poutine ça me fait absolument pas
la porte à la diplomatie américaine on
compte d'ailleurs de nombreux exemples
au xxème siècle de gens qui ont dû
négocier après s'être traité de tous les
noms qu'est-ce que côté américain cette
crise révèle ou modifie pour le coup
dans l'exercice du leadership de
washington vis-à-vis des alliés d'europe
de l'ouest deux choses d'abord
washington s'est trouvée contrainte de
réaffirmer ses garanties de sécurité
existantes les garanties de sécurité
qu'elle apporte à la pologne aux pays
baltes et au reste de l'europe et ça
elle l'a fait et bien fait mais c'est
vrai que les états unis sont bien
embêtés c'était pas dur rien ne se passe
comme prévu c'est souvent comme ça la
vie internationale où les vies de cours
rien ne se passe comme prévu l'américain
est prévu de se réorienter vers l'asie
pour pouvoir se défendre contre la chine
défendre ses alliés montre la chine et
l'amérique se rend compte qu'elle va
être obligé pour un bout de temps pour
quelque temps pour quelques années sans
doute au moins deux réinvestis a
militairement l'europe que c'est
absolument pas ce qu'elle souhaitait on
verra dans deux ans on ne sait pas du
tout où on sera dans deux ans il est
possible surtout ces messieurs trump est
réélu nous verrons il est possible que
dans un tel cas l'amérique dit vraiment
à l'europe dont vous êtes réarmer
maintenant c'est vous qui allez défendre
le continent why un côté un peu
paradoxal on a vu la semaine en fin de
semaine dernière une unité du bloc
occidental comme on l'avait pas vu
depuis longtemps à cette photo de
famille de l'otan bien sûr et et de
l'autre côté des européens qui ont bien
compris qu'ils devaient
gagner voilà renforcer leur autonomie
oui renforcer leur défense leur
autonomie c'est pas totalement gagné
voyez aujourd'hui c'est plus un
renforcement de l'otan car en forcément
de l'europe de la défense et en même
temps tous les efforts nationaux de
défense et finalement ils sont
bénéfiques à la fois pour l'organisation
transatlantique et pour ce qu'on ferait
simplement entre européens ça je crois
qu'il est vraiment un réveil stratégique
de l'europe ça va rester est ce que ça
veut dire que les européens seront moins
dépendants des états unis pour leur
défense j'en suis pas certain il ya des
camps l'allemagne dit je vais te mais je
vais dépenser 100 milliards de plus pour
la défense et puis quelle qu'elles
achètent de 35 appareils
f-35 justement pour pour garantir
l'ancrage de sa défense avec les états
unis on voit bien que les américains on
voit bien que les européens ne sont pas
prêts à cette fameuse autonomie
stratégique pour revenir au président
américain vous lisiez à l'instant il
s'est retrouvé contraint sur un front de
politique étrangère européen lui qui
avait des yeux rivés vers la chine la
chine qui répétait il y a encore
quelques jours semaines ces liens
d'amitié indéfectibles avec la russie
est ce que pékin a quelque chose à
gagner ou à perdre de l'isolément de la
russie mais je pense que la chine est
dans une situation qu'elle n'avait pas
prévu elle pensait on elle non plus en
fait je crois qu'elle est un peu embêté
elle ne veut pas que la russie soit trop
forcée elle ne veut pas non plus que la
russie soit trop faible on dit souvent à
juste titre que al'inverse de la guerre
froide le couple sino russe est un
couple déséquilibré mais pas dans le
même sens à l'époque les chine était
faible la russie et l union soviétique
et des fortes demain aujourd'hui déjà et
demain ça va être l'un vertes mais la
chine a besoin d'un partenaire russe qui
soit capable de d'agir avec elle pas
seulement militairement et politiquement
économiquement pour contrer l'occident
une russie trop faible ça ne l'intéresse
pas dont il est à peu près certain que
la russie va augmenter accroître ses
liens avec la république populaire de
chine mais je crois que la chine ne veut
pas d'une russie trop faible et puis il
ya un deuxième élément c'est que les
sanctions imposées à la russie s'est
fait peut-être réfléchir les chine pour
ce qu'il se passerait si un jour il
devait y avoir une guerre à propos de
taïwan la chine non plus ne sait pas ne
s'attendait pas à une réaction aussi
vives des pays occidentaux précisément
il ya cette ligne de crête des
occidentaux vis-à-vis du conflit en
ukraine et descend intervenir qu est ce
que la chine peut en comprendre dans son
dans son périmètre régional ça peut à la
fois les frais y ait ou pas alors il ya
quand même une très grande différence
c'est que il ya des garanties de
sécurité qu'elles étaient apportées par
les états unis de manière très ferme et
réaffirmée sous bail donne au japon à la
corée du sud et même à taïwan
l'engagement américain envers taiwan n'a
jamais été aussi fort alors que dans
lequel du club on n'avait jamais dit les
américains n'avaient jamais dit nous
défendrons l'ukraine vous voyez quand
même une grande différence donc pékin se
tromperait si elle estimait que notre
retenue vis-à-vis de ce qu'on peut faire
en ukraine dit quoi que ce soit
vis-à-vis de ce que l'amérique pourrait
faire pour défendre le japon la corée du
sud ou taiwan donc il faut pas que la
chine fasse un mauvais calcul
malheureusement l'histoire du monde
l'histoire des relations internationales
est rempli de mauvais calcul à commencer
par celui qui a fait monsieur poutine il
ya un mois on va continuer à se déplacer
si vous le voulez bien sur la mappemonde
ça fait du bien si on essaie de changer
dax de regard comment est-ce que cette
opération rue cette invasion russe de
l'ukraine est elle perçue je pense au
continent africain dans toute sa
diversité et sa complexité évidemment
mais où on connaît les velléités russe
et notamment en afrique de l'ouest en ce
moment comment est ce qu'on regarde ce
qui se passe au nord avec un mélange
d'indifférence de curiosité et de alors
il ya un mot allemand qui est
difficilement traduisible ses charges de
fraude c'est à dire on se complaît dans
la souffrance de l'autre c'est un peu
dur ce que je dis mais il ya beaucoup de
gens en afrique ou au moyen-orient en
asie qui se disent c'est très bien que
les occidentaux comprennent aussi ce que
c'est que la guerre la souffrance et
puis d'ailleurs l'occident est trop
arrogant trop puissant ça c'est quelque
chose que malheureusement on entend
beaucoup dans le reste du monde et en
même temps faudrait pas dire que
l'occident est totalement isolé
l'agression russe c'est une agression
qui est reconnu comme tel par la
majorité des pays du monde et on ne peut
pas dire l'occident est isolé on ne peut
pas dire non plus la cause de l'ukraine
est une cause mondialement
accepté et reconnu par tous sur le
continent africain ce qui est
intéressant c'est que la majorité des
pays qui se sont abstenus dans l'or lors
de la première résolution de l'onu à
propos du cren c'était des pays
africains justement ils savent très bien
que la russie est un pays avec lequel il
faut compter désormais sur le continent
depuis que rt a été suspendue en europe
rta basculer ses efforts vers l'afrique
en particulier donc voyez aurier à la
fois à 100 iman de distance vis à vis de
ce qui se passe en ukraine en afrique et
dans d'autres régions du monde est aussi
un terrain de reconquête par la russie
de son influence mondiale mais la russie
est vraiment dans un combat de longue
durée contre l'occident qui ne se
limitent absolument pas au domaine
militaire et qui ne se limitent
absolument pas l'ukraine on parle de
séparation économique d'agressivité
verbale de menace nucléaire de
compétition et des eaux logique
l'histoire ne se répète pas mais ça
ressemble à quoi mais elle bégaie un
petit peu quand même c'est à dire qu'à
force de dire depuis dix ans non ce
n'est pas une nouvelle guerre froide
c'est différent je crois qu'il faut
finir par reconnaître que ça commence à
ressembler à la guerre froide dans le
temps mais avec une guerre froide qui
sera forcément très différentes ce qui
se déroulera sur des terrains différents
le cyber la guerre de l'information ça
n'existait pas dans cette ampleur et de
cette manière pendant la vraie guerre
froide une guerre froide dont où on aura
une chine beaucoup plus forte et sans
doute une russie plus faible mais dès
lors qu'on a une compétition à l'échelle
mondiale entre des systèmes et même des
idéologies par william née de théologie
russes et chinoises anti-occidentale la
promotion d'un capitalisme autoritaire
tout ça ça commence à ressembler non pas
un bloc parce que l'alliance sino-russe
c'est quand même pas un bloc au sens du
pacte de varsovie c'est un couple un
couple solide mais un couple qui a ses
limites aussi voilà ils font chambre à
part si vous voulez ils sont pas non
plus c'est pas l'amour fou c'est un
mariage de raison on va dire mais ça
commence quand même à ressembler un
petit peu une guerre froide tout
dépendra évidemment la manière dont la
russie sortira de ce conflit est ce
qu'elle sera affaiblie très affaibli est
ce qu'elle va réussir au contraire à
renverser la vapeur ce que je ne crois
pas donc c'est ça qui déterminera les
contours de cette future nouvelle guerre
froide avec deux hommes d'ailleurs qui
ont été fascinés façonné par la guerre
froide puis pas fasciné joba et
d'honnête et vladimir poutine merci
beaucoup bruno tertrais est revenu ce
matin sur le plateau de paray direct
merci pour vos analyses tout bonne
journée